It's peak pollination season and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speed. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans start at $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的生意规模正在迅速扩大。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有顶级优先数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢最繁忙的时候，我的连接依然稳固。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是一个不会一直有的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
GoogleFi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Between raising young children, climbing the career ladder, and handling the everyday demands of adult life, the 30s and 40s can be a particularly busy time for many people. But for years, researchers didn't pay much attention to the period of life between ages 30 and 45, sandwiched between young adulthood and middle age. Today we're going to talk to a developmental psychologist about what she calls established adulthood and what she's found about people's experiences during this life stage. Are most people especially stressed or unhappy during this busy time of life?
GoogleFi Wireless 在网络使用高峰期不会受到数据流量降速的影响。在抚养年幼子女、攀登职业阶梯以及应对成人生活的日常琐事之间，30 多岁和 40 多岁对许多人来说可能是一个特别忙碌的时期。但多年来，研究人员并没有太关注 30 岁到 45 岁之间这段介于成年早期和中年之间的人生阶段。今天，我们将与一位发展心理学家探讨她所称的“确立成年期”（established adulthood），以及她对人们在这一人生阶段经历的发现。在这个忙碌的人生阶段，大多数人是否特别感到压力或不快乐？
Or are there rewards that balance out the stressors? What happens to our friendships and other relationships in our 30s and 40s? Why is it useful to think about this time of life as its own developmental stage? And what does the research suggest about how we could better support people during this time? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Claire Mehta, an associate professor of psychology at Emmanuel College in Boston, where she leads the Lifespan Lab. She is also a staff
还是说，有一些回报可以平衡这些压力源？在 30 多岁和 40 多岁时，我们的友谊和其他关系会发生什么变化？为什么将这段人生时期视为一个独立的发展阶段是有益的？研究对于我们如何在此期间更好地支持人们有什么建议？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是 Kim Mills。我今天的嘉宾是波士顿伊曼纽尔学院的心理学副教授 Claire Mehta 博士，她在那里领导着“生命周期实验室”（Lifespan Lab）。她同时也是一位
scientist at Boston Children's Hospital. Dr. Mehta is a developmental psychologist who studies human development across the lifespan. Her current research is focused on established adulthood that period of life between ages 30 and 45. Dr. Meda, thank you for joining me today. Thank you so much for having me. I'm excited to be able to talk about my research. Great. Well, you first came up with the concept of established adulthood a few years ago,
波士顿儿童医院的科学家。Mehta 博士是一位研究人类全生命周期发展的心理学家。她目前的研究重点是“确立成年期”，即 30 岁到 45 岁之间的人生阶段。Mehta 博士，感谢您今天加入我的节目。非常感谢您的邀请。我很高兴能谈谈我的研究。太好了。嗯，您几年前首次提出了“确立成年期”这个概念，
and it's still new in the psychology literature. So can you start by telling us what is established adulthood? What inspired you to come up with this new theory of human development? All right. Well, I'm going to start with the story of what, inspired me and then I'll tell you a little bit about it because these things really fit quite well together. So at the time that I came up with it, I was about 37 years old. So I was an established adult myself. And I remember there were a couple of things that were happening. So I had
它在心理学文献中仍然是一个新概念。那么，您能先告诉我们什么是“确立成年期”吗？是什么启发您提出了这个新的人类发展理论？好的。嗯，我先讲讲启发我的故事，然后再向您介绍一下它，因为这两者结合得非常好。在我提出这个概念的时候，我大约 37 岁。所以我自己就是一个“确立成年人”。我记得当时发生了一些事情。我有
friends who were getting divorced, who were having children. Some people were getting married. People were all trying to work really hard at work. I actually had a friend who lost a child, which seemed just so kind of awful and traumatic to be happening. And I was teaching lifespan developmental psychology, and I also teach child development, adolescent development, and adulthood and aging. And I saw all of this stuff happening and thought, why is no one studying this age period?
朋友正在离婚，有的正在生孩子。有些人正在结婚。大家都在工作中非常努力。我的一位朋友甚至失去了孩子，这看起来真是太可怕、太痛苦了。当时我正在教授生命周期发展心理学，我也教授儿童发展、青少年发展以及成年与老龄化课程。我看到所有这些事情发生，心想，为什么没有人研究这个年龄段？
There is so much that is going on. All of my friends seem to be dealing with so many different things and trying to balance and juggle all of these different components of their lives. and something else happened around the same time, which was I looked at my bookcase and realized that I wasn't going to live long enough to read all the books I had amassed, which sounds a bit depressing,
这里面发生的事情太多了。我所有的朋友似乎都在处理各种不同的事情，试图平衡和兼顾他们生活中所有这些不同的组成部分。而且大约在同一时间发生了另一件事，我看着我的书架，意识到我活不到读完我所积累的所有书籍的那一天了，这听起来有点令人沮丧，
but it actually didn't feel depressing to me. It felt really freeing. And so I actually went through my books and I got rid of all the things I weren't interested in, which, funnily enough, the infant development books were the first ones to go, and I like to joke about it now because I just had a baby, and I'm like, oh, I wish I'd kept those books.
但实际上我并没有感到沮丧。我感到非常自由。于是我翻看了我的书，处理掉了所有我不感兴趣的东西，有趣的是，婴儿发展书籍是第一批被处理掉的，我现在喜欢拿这个开玩笑，因为我刚生了一个孩子，我心想，哦，我真希望我留着那些书。
But, you know, I just, it felt kind of freeing. So I realized all of these things were happening. No one was studying it. And so it was, you know, people joke around research as me search. And I had this moment of, well, what about me? All of these things are going on and no one is talking about it. And it seemed really bizarre to me. And at the same time, a few months later, I was at a conference in Romania and I saw Jeff
但是，你知道，我只是觉得这是一种解脱。所以我意识到所有这些事情都在发生。没有人研究它。所以，你知道，人们常开玩笑说研究就是“自我研究”（me-search）。我当时有种感觉，那“我呢”？所有这些事情都在发生，却没有人谈论它。这对我来说真的很奇怪。与此同时，几个月后，我在罗马尼亚参加一个会议，我看到 Jeff
Arnett talking about his period of development, emerging adulthood, which is the one that comes before established adulthood, which is ages, roughly ages 18 to 29. And as I listened to him talk about that, again, I was thinking, what about the next stage? What happens when you're in your 30s and early 40s before you reach midlife? And so I actually went and chatted to him and I was taking a sabbatical, so I went and spent it at Clark University.
Arnett 在谈论他的发展阶段——“成年初期”（emerging adulthood），这是在“确立成年期”之前的阶段，大约是 18 到 29 岁。当我听他谈论那个阶段时，我再次想到，下一个阶段呢？当你 30 多岁和 40 多岁出头，还没到中年时会发生什么？所以我去和他聊了聊，当时我正在休学术假，于是我就在克拉克大学度过了那段时光。
And he helped me figure out how to build out this theory. And so to answer the first question, what is established adulthood? Hopefully you've got a sense of it now just from me kind of describing the things I was noticing. But it's this period from 30 to 45. Some researchers have described this period of the lifespan as the rush hour of life. And I think you can really think of it that way. So a lot of people are trying to get ahead in a chosen career, trying to maintain a romantic relationship,
他帮助我弄清楚了如何构建这个理论。所以回答第一个问题，什么是“确立成年期”？希望您现在从我描述我所注意到的事情中已经有了一些了解。它是从 30 岁到 45 岁这一时期。一些研究人员将这一生命周期描述为“人生的高峰时段”。我认为你确实可以这样想。很多人都在试图在选择的职业中出人头地，试图维持一段浪漫关系，
making decisions about having children or having children and then having to raise young children. at the same time that you're trying, hopefully, to maintain some friendships in all of this and some semblance of a social life, but you also have aging parents. So all of these things are kind of colliding at the same time. So we talk about a career and care crunch that takes place during this period. So that's probably the defining feature of established adulthood. And how is it different from emerging adulthood, right, 18 to 29, and then middle age, old age? I mean, what are, all of the developmental stages and how are they different and the same? Yeah, so I think that's a great question. And for people who aren't familiar with how we think about the lifespan as developmental psychologists, we carve it up. And I can come back to that too in a few moments why it's
决定是否要孩子，或者已经有了孩子，然后不得不抚养年幼的孩子。与此同时，你还希望在这一切中维持一些友谊和某种社交生活，但你还有年迈的父母。所以所有这些事情都在同一时间发生碰撞。因此，我们谈论的是这一时期发生的“职业与照护紧缩”（career and care crunch）。这可能是“确立成年期”的决定性特征。它与“成年初期”（18 到 29 岁）以及中年、老年有什么不同？我的意思是，所有的发展阶段是什么，它们有何不同和相同之处？是的，我认为这是一个很好的问题。对于那些不熟悉我们心理学家如何看待生命周期的人来说，我们将其进行了划分。我稍后可以再回到这个问题，谈谈为什么我们这样划分可能并不总是最好的，但我们谈论婴儿期，然后是童年期，接着是青春期。有趣的是，顺便说一句，青春期直到 20 世纪初才存在。所以我们仍然认为它是一个相对较新的发展阶段。然后到了 18 岁，你进入“成年初期”。然后我们有 30 岁开始的“确立成年期”。然后是中年，我认为大约从 45 岁开始，一直持续到 65 岁。然后是老年，又被划分为“年轻的老年人”、“年老的老年人”和“最年长的老年人”。所以有很多空间来划分所有这些时期。我认为“确立成年期”最特别的地方在于——我会将其与它前后的时期进行比较和对比，
maybe not always great to carve up the way that we do, but we talk about infancy, then we have childhood, then we have adolescence. And interestingly enough, by the way, adolescence didn't exist until the early 1900. So that's still, we think of it as a relatively new developmental period. And then at 18, you move into this emerging adulthood. Then we have established adulthood that starts at 30. And then midlife, I would argue, starts at about 45. And that goes until 65. And then we have older adulthood, which has been carved up into the young old, the old old, and the oldest old. So there's lots of space to carve up all of these periods. And I think, think what's so different about established adulthood, and I'll compare and contrast it to the periods
即“成年初期”和中年——当你处于“成年初期”时，你还在弄清楚你是谁，你想要什么，你想去哪里。我并不是说当你到了 30 多岁和 40 多岁时这种情况就不再发生了，因为令人惊讶的是，我的研究实际上表明它仍在发生。但是，确实存在一些非常大的差异。如果我们考虑浪漫关系等事情，当你处于“成年初期”，即 18 到 29 岁时，它们最初是那种短暂的关系。所以你可能和某人在一起六个月、一年或两年。
on either side of it, so emerging adulthood and midlife, when you're in emerging adulthood, you're still figuring out who you are, what you want to be, and where you want to go. And I'm not saying that's not still happening when you reach your 30s and 40s, because surprisingly, my research has actually suggested that it is still happening. But there's, there are some really big differences. So if we think about things like romantic relationships, when you are an emerging adult, when you're 18 to 29, they start off being kind of transient relationships. So you might be with someone for six months or a year or two years.
最终当你接近这个阶段的尾声时，浪漫关系会变得稍微长期一些。而当你处于“确立成年期”时，大多数都是长期关系，然后可能会转变为承诺关系，即婚姻或某种承诺伴侣关系。然后发生的另一件事是，在“确立成年期”中，人们开始离婚和分居。所以这看起来有点不同。职业也非常不同，我认为在“成年初期”，人们真的在努力
And eventually when you get toward the end of it, the romantic relationships become a little bit more long term. And whereas when you're in established adulthood, most of them are long-term relationships that then may turn into committed relationships, so marriage or some kind of committed partnership. And then the other thing that happens in a sense, established adulthood as people start to get divorced and separated. And so that looks a little bit different. And career is very different to, I think in emerging adulthood, people are really trying
弄清楚他们对什么职业感兴趣。所以他们有很多工作变动。有很多研究表明，人们在探索和弄清楚他们真正想做什么时，换工作的频率非常高。因此，我们可以认为那个职业发展阶段实际上是信息收集和探索。但当你成为一名“确立成年人”时，希望如此，而且这一时期的大多数成年人都决定致力于某个领域。所以他们正在建立这种专业知识，他们正在建立责任感，人们带着问题来找他们，而且有更多的稳定性。所以你从一年到下一年都知道，即使不是在完全相同的工作岗位上，你也可能在同一个行业和同一个职业中。当你到了
to figure out what career they're interested in. So they have a lot of job changes. There's a lot of research that suggests that people are changing jobs very frequently as they explore and figure out what they actually want to do. And so we can think of that period of career development as really being information gathering and exploration. But then when you are an established adult, hopefully, and most adults in this period have decided to commit to a field. And so they're building this expertise, they're building responsibility, people are coming to them with things, and there's more stability. So you kind of know from year to year that you're likely to be, if not in the exact same job, in the same profession and the same career. And by the time you get to
中年时，你有很多资历。你拥有了这种获得的专业知识，所以你不再需要建立它了。你已经拥有了它。你开始指导下一代。我总是喜欢讲一个关于这个的故事，因为我丈夫比我大一点，他的一位 40 多岁的朋友谈到她工作场所的许多资深人士退休了。她突然意识到自己成了资深人士，并产生了一种恐慌，因为现在人们在需要建议和指导时会来找我。而且，你知道，她觉得还没完全准备好。但我认为，这确实是一个很好的故事，说明了这种转变，
midlife, you have a lot of seniority. You've got this acquired expertise, so you're not building it anymore. You have it. And you start mentoring the next generation. And I always like to tell a story about this because my husband's a little bit older than me and one of his friends who's in her late 40s talked about a lot of the senior people at her place of work, retiring. And she suddenly realized that she was the senior person and kind of having this panic that now people are coming to me when they need advice and they need mentoring. And I, you know, she didn't feel quite ready for it. But I think that that really, that was a great story that kind of illustrates this transition
从那个还在弄清楚事情的人，变成了现在被期望知道答案的人。然后就家庭而言，当你处于“成年初期”，也就是 18 到 29 岁时，大多数人——我确实想说明，并非所有人。所以人们的生活状况确实存在一些人口统计学上的差异。但对于很多人来说，他们至少在“成年初期”开始时是未婚的，
from being the person who's still figuring things out to now being expected to know the answers. And then in terms of family, when you're an emerging adult, so again, 18 to 29, most people, and I do want to be clear, not all. So there are really some demographic differences in what people's lives look like. But for a lot of people, they're unmarried, at least. at the beginning of emerging adulthood, and this is very specific to the US, likely to be child free and still getting support from parents. So again, this is, you know, even as I'm talking about this, I'm like, this sounds very middle class. But if we're looking at the middle class,
很可能是没有孩子的，并且仍然从父母那里获得支持。所以，再次强调，即使我在谈论这个，我也觉得这听起来非常中产阶级。但如果我们着眼于中产阶级，
this is kind of what things look like. And then when you get to established adulthood, it's more likely, especially by the time people are in their 40s, that they're married, they may have children, be thinking about having children or have made decisions not to have children. And then again have these aging parents they're looking after. And then at midlife, people have been married for some time. Those relationships are really kind of strong, stable relationships. Some people are on their second relationship by midlife too if they've separated or been divorced. And then there are older children who hopefully need less support. I shouldn't say less support. It's a different kind of support. They don't need their, you know, diapers, nappies to be changed, but they probably do
事情看起来就是这样。然后当你进入“确立成年期”时，更有可能的是，特别是到人们 40 多岁时，他们已经结婚，可能有孩子，正在考虑要孩子，或者已经决定不要孩子。然后同样有这些需要照顾的年迈父母。然后到了中年，人们已经结婚一段时间了。那些关系确实是那种强大、稳定的关系。有些人到中年时已经是第二段关系了，如果他们分居或离婚的话。然后还有年龄较大的孩子，希望他们需要较少的支持。我不应该说较少的支持。这是一种不同类型的支持。他们不需要换尿布了，但他们可能确实
want a little bit of money every now and again. So, you know, or need to come home for for little spots of time as they're figuring out their life. So, you know, for people at midlife, parenting definitely looks a bit different. And then you're either going through the loss of parents or adjusting to loss of parents or kind of living your life without your parents around. So as you can see, there's lots of different things going on in all of these periods. But there is some overlap. So as they said, there are some emerging adults who find their careers earlier, who, who do get married and have children earlier as well. So it's not exact, but if we're kind of looking at averages, which we do in psychology,
偶尔想要一点钱。所以，你知道，或者在他们弄清楚自己生活的时候需要回家住上一小段时间。所以，你知道，对于中年人来说，育儿看起来确实有点不同。然后你要么正在经历失去父母的过程，要么正在适应失去父母，或者过着没有父母在身边的生活。所以正如你所看到的，在所有这些时期都有很多不同的事情发生。但确实有一些重叠。所以正如他们所说，有些“成年初期”的人更早地找到了职业，更早地结婚生子。所以它并不精确，但如果我们是在看平均值，我们在心理学中就是这样做的，
you can see that there are some things that make these stages all distinguishable from one another. Right. And a lot of research has found that people are less happy in midlife than at other life stages, maybe because this is just such an intense and busy time, as you've just described. How does this track with what you found in your research when you reach established adulthood, are you happy or are you too busy to even think about being happy? That is a very good point and a very good question too. So I love this question because it's one of my favorite answers to give to anything in psychology as well as complicated.
你可以看到有一些事情使这些阶段彼此可区分。是的。许多研究发现，人们在中年时比在其他人生阶段更不快乐，也许是因为正如你刚才所描述的那样，这是一个如此紧张和忙碌的时期。这与您在研究中的发现有何关联？当你达到“确立成年期”时，你是快乐的，还是忙得连考虑快乐的时间都没有？这是一个非常好的观点，也是一个非常好的问题。所以我喜欢这个问题，因为这也是我在心理学中回答任何问题时最喜欢的答案之一：这很复杂。
So it's complicated because people are busy and when I talk to people who see people in therapy who have like clinical practice, you do hear lots of stories of people kind of struggling to manage everything. But the interviews I've done, so I've done, I think it's close to 180 interviews at this point with established adults. I'm hearing a little bit of a different story. Now, some of them are in therapy, not all of them are. And one of the things that I think is so fabulous about this period of the lifespan is that people are now reflecting a little bit on where they are and making peace with where they are and are able to find happiness. So one of the people who I interviewed had talked about how they really had wanted to become a doctor, but they ended up not doing that, but they went into the medical field doing
这很复杂，因为人们很忙，当我与那些在临床实践中接待患者的治疗师交谈时，你确实会听到很多关于人们努力管理一切的故事。但我所做的采访——我想目前我已经对“确立成年人”进行了近 180 次采访——我听到的是一个稍微不同的故事。现在，他们中有些人正在接受治疗，并非所有人都是。我认为这一生命周期最美妙的事情之一是，人们现在正在反思他们所处的位置，与现状达成和解，并能够找到幸福。所以我采访过的一个人谈到，他们曾经非常想成为一名医生，但最终没有做到，而是进入了医疗领域，做了一些
something more on the business side. And they said, you know, I always thought I wanted to be a doctor, but I didn't do it. And now I'm doing this job. And this is actually okay. Like I like it. It's a good fit for me. And it works for my life. And so there's a lot of people kind of reflecting and looking back and thinking, you know, this is working out okay. It's not as bad as I thought it was going to be. And I think that other really positive thing that happens during this period is people feel like they know themselves better. So they have more confidence in who they are and what they're able to do. And again, some of my favorite stories that I heard was people saying, you know, my mother, she always used to try and dominate me and tell me that I needed to do this and
更偏向商业方面的事情。他们说：“你知道，我一直以为我想成为一名医生，但我没做到。现在我做这份工作。这其实还可以。我喜欢它。它很适合我。它对我的生活有效。”所以很多人在反思和回顾，心想：“你知道，这还不错。它没有我想象的那么糟糕。”我认为在这一时期发生的另一件非常积极的事情是，人们觉得他们更了解自己了。所以他们对自己是谁以及自己能做什么更有信心。同样，我听到的一些我最喜欢的故事是人们说：“你知道，我母亲，她总是试图支配我，告诉我我需要做这个，
I needed to do that and I just don't care anymore. That is not who I am. And so I'm going to be myself. So a lot more confidence, a lot more self-understanding. And I think with that comes a lot of happiness. And one of the things that I always think of when people ask me about happiness too, and you can tell from my voice that I'm from England originally. And so I have a very European outlook on life, even though I've been living in the US for a long time. And so there was a study that I really appreciated by glass and colleagues. And what they did was they looked at a number of different European countries and the US and Canada. And they looked at this idea of well-being and how when people have children, so again, usually in this established adulthood stage,
我需要做那个，但我再也不在乎了。那不是我。所以我要做我自己。”所以有更多的自信，更多的自我理解。我认为随之而来的是很多幸福感。当人们问我关于幸福的问题时，我总是会想到一件事，你可以从我的口音听出我最初来自英国。所以我对生活有一种非常欧洲的看法，尽管我在美国生活了很长时间。所以有一项由 Glass 及其同事进行的研究，我非常欣赏。他们所做的是观察了许多不同的欧洲国家以及美国和加拿大。他们研究了幸福感的概念，以及当人们有了孩子时——所以通常是在这个“确立成年期”阶段，
we talk about there being this huge dip in well-being. And what they discovered was that in countries with good social support, so countries that give good maternity leave, that provide universal childcare, that dip doesn't actually happen in well-being when you have children. In In fact, people have increases in well-being when they have children. And because the U.S. has the fewest, in this study, they had the fewest number of social safety nets. I think that's why we see some of the dip. And so this, to me, is one of the big implications of what we should be doing with this work, is thinking about how we can support people in this age period to ensure that they are able to be happy and healthy and function well.
我们谈论的是幸福感会出现巨大的下滑。而他们发现的是，在社会支持良好的国家，即提供良好产假、提供全民托儿服务的国家，当你有了孩子时，幸福感实际上并不会出现那种下滑。事实上，人们在有了孩子时幸福感会增加。因为美国在这一研究中拥有的社会安全网数量最少，我认为这就是为什么我们看到了一些下滑。所以对我来说，这是我们应该利用这项工作所带来的重大启示之一，即思考我们如何才能支持这一年龄段的人，确保他们能够快乐、健康并良好地运作。
Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next. next grill four burner gas grill on special buy for only $199 and entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, US only exclusions apply. See homedipo.com slash price match for details. Have you looked at gender differences in your research?
你的夏天从现在开始，家得宝（The Home Depot）有阵亡将士纪念日的优惠。是时候用 Nextgrill 四炉头燃气烤架开启夏季烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元，并用 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅套装尽情娱乐整个季节，仅需 49 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，适用排除条款。详情请见 homedepot.com/price-match。您在研究中观察过性别差异吗？
men and women share a lot of the same experiences in the 30 to 45 age range or are their lives different? Oh, I love that you ask this question because before I studied established adulthood, I was actually a gender researcher. And so that was where all of my research was focused. I was a feminist psychologist, was the work that I was doing. And so when I'm interviewing people and hearing the stories, I'm always looking for some of these differences and some of these similarities. And I think one of the biggest differences that I was really looking for was around this career and care crunch and childcare because I really expected to see that women were struggling a little bit more. And to be honest, they are. They are in a lot of ways.
男性和女性在 30 到 45 岁这个年龄段是否有许多相同的经历，还是他们的生活有所不同？哦，我很高兴你问这个问题，因为在我研究“确立成年期”之前，我实际上是一名性别研究人员。所以那是我所有研究的重点。我是一名女性主义心理学家，这就是我当时所做的工作。所以当我采访人们并听取他们的故事时，我总是在寻找其中一些差异和一些相似之处。我认为我一直在寻找的最大差异之一是关于“职业与照护紧缩”和育儿问题，因为我真的预期会看到女性稍微挣扎得更多一些。老实说，她们确实是。她们在很多方面都是如此。
But it was very refreshing to hear male parents really wanting to be involved in their children's lives and feeling the career and care crunch too as they tried to figure out how they could be there. So there was one participant in particular who had two daughters and really wanted to be there for his daughters as they were growing up and was making career choices around that so that he could make sure that he was there to pick them up from school and had kind of put his career to the side to be able to be a good parent. But, you know, there weren't many men who were talking about that. One of the males in the study I remember very clearly, he was asked about the career in Care Crunch and whether he felt like he was. juggling a lot and he said well it's hard to go and play golf for a whole afternoon now that I have two children and after hearing some of the women talking about trying to start their own company and not being able to do the things that they needed to do because of the childcare requirements and it's like and you can't play golf in the afternoon you know so I did there are definitely some gender
但听到男性父母真的想参与到孩子的生活中，并且在试图弄清楚如何能陪伴孩子时也感受到了“职业与照护紧缩”，这非常令人耳目一新。所以有一位参与者特别让我印象深刻，他有两个女儿，真的想在女儿成长过程中陪伴她们，并围绕这一点做出了职业选择，这样他就能确保自己能去接她们放学，并且为了能成为一名好父亲，他把自己的职业放在了一边。但是，你知道，没有多少男性在谈论这一点。我清楚地记得研究中的一名男性，当被问及“职业与照护紧缩”以及他是否觉得自己在
differences and I do think that the career in care crunch certainly hits women to a greater extent than it hits men, even though we would like to think that things are becoming more equal, I think we all know that women still do the lion's share of the childcare and housework as well. So it's definitely a gendered crunch, and we see women suffering a bit more. What about the factors of race and ethnicity? Have you found differences in those cases as well? Yeah. So one of the things that's been really important to me as I've been developing this theory
忙于应付很多事情时，他说：“嗯，现在我有两个孩子了，很难整个下午都去打高尔夫球。”而在听到一些女性谈论试图创办自己的公司，却因为育儿需求而无法做她们需要做的事情之后，这就像是——“你下午不能打高尔夫球，你知道吗？”所以我确实——肯定存在一些性别差异，我确实认为“职业与照护紧缩”对女性的影响程度肯定比对男性的影响更大，尽管我们愿意认为事情正变得越来越平等，但我认为我们都知道女性仍然承担着大部分的育儿和家务劳动。所以这绝对是一种性别化的紧缩，我们看到女性受到的影响更大。那么种族和民族因素呢？您在这些方面也发现了差异吗？是的。在我发展这个理论的过程中，对我来说非常重要的一点是
is to make this not another one of these psychological theories that is just all about white middle class folk because so much of the research that we produce is, those are the participants people are getting. So in my interviews, and I should probably also mention that these interviews, I did them for a book that will be coming out in early 2025. So if people are interested, they can check that out
不要让它成为另一个仅仅是关于白人中产阶级的心理学理论，因为我们产生的大量研究都是如此，那些是人们能得到的参与者。所以在我采访中——我也应该提到，这些采访是我为一本将于 2025 年初出版的书所做的。所以如果人们感兴趣，他们可以去看看
and actually read some of these stories. And so I made sure that I had, I think it was around 50% people of color, and the stories ended up actually being very similar. And I think this is my fault because I think a lot of people were again middle class. So I tried to get more working class folk as well and to interview people who didn't have college degrees because I think that definitely makes a difference. But because I was getting mainly middle class people, a lot of people had the same kind of concerns and the same worries. And I'm not 100% sure that I buy this.
并阅读其中一些故事。所以我确保我大约有 50% 的有色人种参与者，故事最终实际上非常相似。我认为这是我的错，因为我认为很多人再次是中产阶级。所以我试图获得更多的工人阶级，并采访那些没有大学学位的人，因为我认为这绝对会有所不同。但因为我主要接触的是中产阶级，很多人都有同样的担忧和同样的焦虑。我不 100% 确定我认同这一点。
So this is one of the areas that I want to delve into a little bit more. And I did try to do a good job of making sure that if you were a person of color, you were matched by race, so you were being interviewed by someone who had a similar ethnic or racial background to you, because I think that makes people more comfortable to be able to talk about their experiences, especially of racism. They're probably not going to feel comfortable talking to someone who's white about some of those experiences. And so I heard here and there some discussions of how race had impacted their lives, but generally people in this age period were all coping with the same things. So trying to juggle children, trying to figure out what they were doing for work. And so it seemed at least in the middle classes that a lot of the concerns were the same.
所以这是我想深入研究的领域之一。我确实努力做得很好，确保如果你是有色人种，你的采访者在种族上是匹配的，所以你是被一个与你有相似民族或种族背景的人采访的，因为我认为这会让人们在谈论他们的经历时感到更自在，特别是关于种族主义的经历。他们可能不会觉得和白人谈论其中一些经历很自在。所以我在这里和那里听到了一些关于种族如何影响他们生活的讨论，但总的来说，这个年龄段的人都在应对同样的事情。试图兼顾孩子，试图弄清楚他们在工作中做什么。所以至少在中产阶级中，很多担忧似乎是一样的。
The common wisdom is that it gets harder to make friends as you get older and even to stay in touch with the friends that you have. What have you found about people's friendships and support systems during established adulthood? Yeah, that's another great question. And I said that I studied gender before I studied gender and friendships. So these are the things that I've really been paying attention to. And so the friendship stuff I was really, really interested in, because in terms of my research, this was also how I got into established adulthood. I did a friendship study first, looking at gender and friendships and the tendency for women to be friends with women
普遍的看法是，随着年龄的增长，结交朋友变得越来越难，甚至与现有的朋友保持联系也变得越来越难。您在“确立成年期”期间对人们的友谊和支持系统有什么发现？是的，这是另一个很好的问题。我说过我在研究性别之前研究过性别和友谊。所以这些是我一直在真正关注的事情。我对友谊的事情非常非常感兴趣，因为就我的研究而言，这也是我进入“确立成年期”的方式。我先做了一项友谊研究，观察性别与友谊，以及女性倾向于与女性交朋友，
and men to be friends with men, and what that looks like in adulthood when we regard cross-gender friendships with suspicion. And so in terms of what these social networks look like, it gets really difficult for people in established adulthood. This is another area that is ripe for research and intervention. So the quote that stands out in my mind the most from one of my participants, she said, my friendship circle is really a dot. And so she described, how she had lots and lots of friends when she was an emerging adult, when she was in college, when she was first working, and that as she got older and took on more responsibilities and had a romantic partner, had children, she just didn't have time to see her friends anymore. So she said
男性倾向于与男性交朋友，以及当我们以怀疑的眼光看待跨性别友谊时，这在成年期是什么样子的。所以就这些社交网络的样子而言，对于“确立成年期”的人来说变得非常困难。这是另一个成熟的研究和干预领域。我脑海中最突出的参与者的一句话是，她说：“我的朋友圈真的只是一个点。”所以她描述了
something like, in theory, I have friends. I just don't see them. And we see this, I think pretty much everyone I interviewed, whether they were partnered, whether they had children, talked about this retraction and friendships that they had few. were friends. And one of the things that happens is people move. So this is something that we think about as happening a lot in emerging adulthood as people are exploring careers and figuring out who they are where they want to live. But it's happening in established adulthood too. And I think a lot of this has to do with the cost of property as well and how difficult it is for people to own now that maybe, you know, 30 or 40 years ago, people were buying houses when they were emerging adults. Now you
当她是“成年初期”时，当她在大学时，当她刚开始工作时，她有很多很多朋友，而随着她年龄增长，承担了更多责任，有了浪漫伴侣，有了孩子，她就没有时间再见她的朋友了。所以她说
can't afford to do until you're an established adult. So you may have been living, in a city or in an area that was a little bit more expensive and you realize you can't afford to live in this place if you want to buy a house so you have to move. And some people as they advance up that career ladder are getting career offers that also require them to move. So a lot of friends are moving away. People are too busy with their children, with their families. There's also this cultural assumption that we make that if you are partnered, you do not need friends, that your partner will provide everything for you, which is an absolute lie. One of my favorite non-psychology writers is Annie Lamott. And my favorite saying that I heard from her is you cannot get bread from a
类似这样的话：“理论上，我有朋友。我只是见不到他们。”我们看到这一点，我认为我采访的几乎每个人，无论他们是否有伴侣，无论他们是否有孩子，都谈到了这种友谊的萎缩，他们拥有的朋友很少。发生的一件事是人们搬家。所以这是我们认为在“成年初期”发生很多的事情，因为人们在探索职业并弄清楚他们是谁，他们想住在哪里。但这在“确立成年期”也在发生。我认为这很大程度上也与房产成本有关，以及人们现在拥有房产有多么困难，也许，你知道，30 或 40 年前，人们在“成年初期”时就在买房。现在你
hardware store. And I have to remind myself this with my husband, if I want something from him, if I want him to give me like warm fuzzies and validate my feelings, he's not going to do that. I need my friends to do that. And so it's really important for people to keep the social support. I would argue that our society isn't really set up to do that. So we have these cultural beliefs that if you're partnered, you're all set, you don't need to have friends because your partner is going to provide everything you need. And then we're also so busy. And there's this grind culture that's going on now where we're always competing. Like, who's the busiest?
直到成为“确立成年人”才买得起。所以你可能一直住在城市或一个稍微贵一点的地区，你意识到如果你想买房，你就负担不起住在这个地方，所以你必须搬家。有些人随着他们在职业阶梯上晋升，也会得到需要他们搬家的职业机会。所以很多朋友都搬走了。人们太忙于他们的孩子，他们的家庭。还有一个我们做出的文化假设，即如果你有伴侣，你就不需要朋友，你的伴侣会为你提供一切，这是一个彻头彻尾的谎言。我最喜欢的非心理学作家之一是安妮·拉莫特（Annie Lamott）。我从她那里听到的我最喜欢的一句话是：“你不能从五金店买到面包。”
Who's working the hardest? I just told someone this morning that I'm not going to have time to go and visit them. It was some cousins in Long Island until spring, which seems crazy. But we all do this. We're like too busy, too busy to do things. And so I think this is really dangerous. We know about this loneliness epidemic. I think established adulthood is really where it's taken hold.
我必须提醒自己这一点，关于我丈夫，如果我想要他给我什么，如果我想要他给我那种温暖的感觉并认可我的感受，他不会那样做。我需要我的朋友来做。所以人们保持社会支持真的很重要。我会说我们的社会并没有真正为此做好准备。所以我们有这些文化信仰，即如果你有伴侣，你就一切就绪了，你不需要有朋友，因为你的伴侣会提供你需要的一切。然后我们也太忙了。现在有一种“磨砺文化”（grind culture），我们总是处于竞争状态。比如，谁最忙？
And you have these people in their 30s and 40s who feel as though they don't have a single friend that they can talk to about how they're feeling. And given how much is happening in this age period, those social connections are so important. They can be like a lifeline for people. So I think this is so important for us to be asking. questions about looking at and thinking, thinking about. Why is it important to see life in these stages? Is this just something for psychologists to think about or is it helpful for just regular people to see their lives in these sort of slices? Yeah, that's a great question. I think that it's useful for everybody to look at it this way and it's also not useful. So I'm going to, I'll give you both
谁工作最努力？我今天早上刚告诉某人，我没有时间去拜访他们，那是长岛的一些表亲，直到春天，这听起来很疯狂。但我们都这样做。我们就像太忙了，太忙而无法做事情。所以我认为这真的很危险。我们知道这种孤独流行病。我认为“确立成年期”确实是它扎根的地方。
both thoughts about this. So I think it's useful to be able to say, this is what we expect to be happening roughly around these ages, and this is what these ages should roughly look like. I think we all want to know that we are on track for the things that we want to do in our lives. And so having these stages kind of helps us with that. It also helps us just understand what our lifespan looks like, that we go through these phases of life. And I think all of us, even if we're not psychologist just in terms of our lives feel these different phases. We feel very different. And, you know, I remember my mom telling me she still feels like she's 17. And I'm sure she does. She's 83. I'm sure she does in some ways. But I'm sure there are other ways in which she definitely
你有这些 30 多岁和 40 多岁的人，他们觉得好像没有一个朋友可以谈论他们的感受。考虑到这个年龄段发生的事情如此之多，那些社会联系非常重要。它们可以成为人们的生命线。所以我认为这对我们来说非常重要，去提出问题，去观察，去思考。为什么将生活视为这些阶段很重要？这只是心理学家需要思考的事情，还是对于普通人来说，将他们的生活视为这些切片是有帮助的？是的，这是一个很好的问题。我认为每个人这样看都是有用的，同时也是没有用的。所以我会给你两个
does not feel that young anymore. And so we can feel ourselves evolving. And so having these stages and labels to give them, I think is really helpful for us in terms of making sense of our lives and how we're moving through our lives. I do think it's problematic to have these stages because things aren't this clear cut. So I like to say that you don't wake up in the morning. You go to bed at 29 and then you wake up in the morning at 30 and you're like, I am now an established adult. I feel completely different. My life has changed. I'm feeling much more stable. I'm feeling more committed to all of these things in my life. That's not how it happens. And people do things at different stages too. So some of my research looked at people who were Mormon or former Mormons, so people who were
关于这个的想法。所以我认为能够说“这就是我们预期在这些年龄段大致会发生的事情，这就是这些年龄段大致应该看起来的样子”是有用的。我认为我们都想知道我们在生活中想要做的事情是否在轨道上。所以拥有这些阶段在某种程度上对我们有帮助。它也有助于我们理解我们的生命周期是什么样的，我们经历了这些人生阶段。我认为我们所有人，即使我们不是心理学家，就我们的生活而言，都能感受到这些不同的阶段。我们感觉非常不同。而且，你知道，我记得我妈妈告诉我她仍然觉得她 17 岁。我相信她确实是。她 83 岁了。我相信她在某些方面确实是。但我也相信在其他方面她绝对
members of Church of the Latter-day Saints. And it seemed for women, at least, in this group, that established adulthood and emerging adulthood were flipped because they were having children earlier. So they were having children during emerging adulthood and raising their kids. And then they reached established adulthood. And their kids were old enough that they didn't need lots of care anymore. And so people were thinking, well, what do I do with my life? Like, who am I? Where do I want to go? Who do I want to be? What do I want to do for work? And so a lot of the exploration that we associate with emerging adulthood was happening in established adulthood. And so when you see things like that, it's like, do these stages even make sense? Should we just get rid of them completely? And I think
不再觉得那么年轻了。所以我们可以感觉到自己在进化。因此，拥有这些阶段和标签来命名它们，我认为对于我们理解我们的生活以及我们如何度过我们的生活非常有帮助。我确实认为拥有这些阶段是有问题的，因为事情并不那么清晰。所以我喜欢说，你不会在早上醒来。你在 29 岁时上床睡觉，然后你在 30 岁的早上醒来，心想：“我现在是一名确立成年人了。我感觉完全不同。我的生活改变了。我感觉更稳定了。我对生活中的所有这些事情都感觉更投入了。”事情不是这样发生的。人们在不同的阶段也做不同的事情。所以我的一些研究观察了那些是摩门教徒或前摩门教徒的人，也就是耶稣基督后期圣徒教会的成员。对于这一群体中的女性来说，似乎“确立成年期”和“成年初期”是颠倒的，因为她们更早地生了孩子。所以她们在“成年初期”生了孩子并抚养孩子。然后她们达到了“确立成年期”。而她们的孩子已经长大，不再需要太多的照顾了。所以人们在想：“嗯，我该用我的生活做什么？我是谁？我想去哪里？我想成为谁？我想做什么工作？”所以我们与“成年初期”联系在一起的很多探索实际上发生在“确立成年期”。所以当你看到这样的事情时，就像是，这些阶段还有意义吗？我们应该完全摆脱它们吗？我认为
there's a great discussion in psychology about the usefulness of having these stages when we know that development is continuous and it's not, you can think of development as either being a straight line or steps and it's not like a step. You don't wake up in the morning when you go from established adulthood to midlife jumping, having jumped up the next step, you're still slowly changing. You're changing throughout your life very slowly. I like to tell people like every single day you're different than you were the day before. And so we talk about that a lot in psychology, but I think it's still useful to have these life stages so that we can study them. Because if I didn't name established adulthood, I imagine that people still wouldn't be studying it as a unique
在心理学中，关于拥有这些阶段的有用性有一个很好的讨论，当我们知道发展是连续的，它不是——你可以认为发展要么是一条直线，要么是台阶，它不像一个台阶。你不会在从“确立成年期”过渡到中年时，在早上醒来时跳跃，跳上了下一个台阶，你仍然在缓慢地改变。你在你的一生中都在非常缓慢地改变。我喜欢告诉人们，就像每一天你都与前一天不同。所以我们在心理学中经常谈论这一点，但我认为拥有这些人生阶段仍然是有用的，这样我们就可以研究它们。因为如果我不命名“确立成年期”，我想人们仍然不会将其作为一个独特的发展时期来研究。
period of development. So people might be looking at romantic relationships and divorce and child rearing. But without giving it a name, these are the things that are happening in established adulthood. And all of these things are connected to one another. And they're not separate. I think it's so it's really important to have that name that we can unify all of the research under. You mentioned earlier the fact that we don't have as many social safety nets in this country for people at this stage of life. I'm just wondering, what else could we be doing at a policy level to help people in their 30s and 40s? Yeah, so I think the easiest answer to this question is for people who do have children
所以人们可能在观察浪漫关系、离婚和育儿。但如果不给它一个名字，这些就是发生在“确立成年期”的事情。所有这些事情都彼此相关。它们不是分开的。我认为拥有那个我们可以将所有研究统一起来的名字非常重要。您之前提到过，在这个国家，处于这一人生阶段的人没有那么多的社会安全网。我只是想知道，我们在政策层面还能做些什么来帮助 30 多岁和 40 多岁的人？是的，所以我认为这个问题的最简单答案是，对于那些确实有孩子的人来说
is to be able to provide parental leave for both males and for females. this can alleviate this gendered career and care crunch too. So I think that's really helpful. But for people who don't have children, having some kind of family leave policy is going to help if you're looking after aging parents, for example. And I live in Massachusetts, so I'm very lucky that we do have, we have some legislation now that enabled me,
是能够为男性和女性提供育儿假。这也能缓解这种性别化的职业和照护压力。所以我认为这非常有帮助。但对于没有孩子的人来说，如果他们需要照顾年迈的父母，拥有某种家庭假政策也会有所帮助。我住在马萨诸塞州，我很幸运，我们现在有一些立法使我能够，
when I had my baby, I was able to get money from the state to take a slightly longer maternity leave. But it's not as long as a lot of these European countries where we see people being happier and healthier. So I think looking at parental leave, looking at universal childcare, which I would argue any universal education that we provide people benefits the society as a whole.
当我生孩子时，我能够从州政府获得资金，从而休更长的产假。但这并不像我们在许多欧洲国家看到的那样长，在那些国家，人们更快乐、更健康。所以我认为，关注育儿假，关注全民托儿服务，我认为我们为人们提供的任何全民教育都会使整个社会受益。
It's not just the people with the children because those children go on to be earning individuals who provide taxes. And so the more support we can give to these kids throughout their lives and their parents, I think, is really important. And then I also, this isn't really at the policy level, but if we could somehow change our culture and move a little bit more away from this grind culture
这不仅仅是为了有孩子的人，因为这些孩子长大后会成为纳税的劳动者。因此，我认为在他们的一生中以及对他们的父母给予尽可能多的支持是非常重要的。此外，这虽然不是政策层面的，但如果我们能以某种方式改变我们的文化，稍微远离这种“磨砺文化”，
and give each other more space and more time and be more respectful of people's home lives when they're at work. So somebody was telling me that they had met with a German colleague and had asked them, they only needed three more hours done on a project to finish it, but it was five o'clock on a Friday. And the German colleague said, I'm sorry, I'm off the clock. It's five o'clock. I'm leaving. for the weekend and then I'm on vacation for the next two weeks. So I'm not going to work on this. And we don't do that here. If somebody asked me to stay for an extra three hours on a Friday because this really needed to get done, I would just do it. And so I think all of us can
给彼此更多的空间和时间，在工作中更尊重人们的家庭生活。有人告诉我，他们曾与一位德国同事会面，当时项目只需要再花三个小时就能完成，但已经是周五下午五点了。那位德国同事说：“抱歉，我下班了。现在五点了。我要去过周末了，接下来的两周我还要休假。所以我不会再做这个了。”我们这里不会那样做。如果有人让我周五多留三个小时，因为这确实需要完成，我就会照做。所以我认为我们所有人都可以
play a role in this, just setting better boundaries and saying no. And then that will give us more time for our families, more time for friends. And I think, too, one of the big things that I love when I go to the UK is, and it's not because I am a boozy alcoholic, but I love the pub culture there because it's a place for people to gather and you can bring your families. So whenever we're in the UK, we go to the pub and my friends come and they bring their children and there's play areas and the kids run around and they have a great time and the grownups get to talk and really connect with one another and people who don't have children, they get to come to and have a drink and connect and the kids are kind of off entertaining themselves.
发挥作用，设定更好的界限并学会说不。这样我们就能有更多的时间陪伴家人和朋友。而且我认为，我去英国时最喜欢的一点是——这并不是因为我酗酒——我喜欢那里的酒吧文化，因为那是一个人们可以聚会的地方，你可以带上家人。所以每当我们去英国，我们都会去酒吧，我的朋友们会带着孩子一起来，那里有游乐区，孩子们可以跑来跑去，玩得很开心，大人们可以聊天并真正建立联系。没有孩子的人也可以来喝一杯，建立联系，而孩子们则在旁边自娱自乐。
And it's really hard to find spaces like that in the US and opportunity. where you can have kind of everyone just get together and it not be a big deal if there are children there because they're just expected to be off running around and playing and being a little bit loud and messy and nobody really cares. So I think if there was some way we could have more places like that, it would be really helpful for people in this age period. So what's next for you? What are you working on now? What are your big questions that you're looking at? Oh, there's so many things I'm interested in. So I want to delve more into this friendships piece because I think, it's really important and we know that loneliness is really bad for our health and actually at their APA convention in August 2024 this was one of the big themes was loneliness and how we can combat it.
在美国很难找到这样的空间和机会，让大家聚在一起，而如果那里有孩子也不会是什么大问题，因为人们预料到他们会跑来跑去、玩耍、吵闹和弄乱，没人会在意。所以我认为，如果我们能有更多这样的地方，对这个年龄段的人会非常有帮助。那么你接下来的计划是什么？你现在在做什么？你正在关注哪些重大问题？哦，我感兴趣的事情太多了。我想深入研究友谊这个课题，因为我认为这非常重要，而且我们知道孤独对我们的健康非常有害。事实上，在2024年8月的美国心理学会（APA）年会上，孤独感以及我们如何对抗它就是主要议题之一。
And I think again, established adulthood is really the period where this loneliness is really beginning to take hold as people's friends kind of drop off and they get busy. So really figuring out what we can do to support friendships in established adulthood. But then the other thing that I'm most excited about at the moment is really getting a very close look of what it's like to be an established adulthood in terms of just what your daily life looks like. And so there are these very exciting intensive longitudinal studies that you can do. I would like to do it qualitatively. So that means I would be asking people every day for three. I'd love to do it for three months. I have to figure out how I can get funding for this. But I would love over three months to just
我认为，成年期确实是孤独感开始真正扎根的时期，因为朋友们逐渐疏远，生活变得忙碌。所以，真正弄清楚我们能做些什么来支持成年期的友谊非常重要。但我目前最兴奋的另一件事是，近距离观察成年期的日常生活到底是什么样的。有一些非常令人兴奋的密集纵向研究可以做。我想从定性的角度来做。这意味着我会在三个月的时间里每天询问人们。我得想办法获得这方面的资助。但我很乐意在三个月的时间里，
just follow established adults, have a quick phone call with them in the evening. How did your day go? What were some of the challenges? What were some of the rewards? What are the things you're thinking about at the moment? What feels important to you? And just be able to watch that development unfold in real time. I think would be so valuable and just so interesting.
跟踪成年人，在晚上和他们通个简短的电话。你今天过得怎么样？有哪些挑战？有哪些收获？你现在在想些什么？什么对你来说感觉很重要？能够实时观察这种发展过程，我认为会非常有价值，也非常有趣。
And again, to be able to get a diverse sample to look at multiple races, ethnicities in the US to begin with. I mean, if I had loads and loads of money, I would study this across the world. But I think that's something that's really important because it's going to tell us and give us more details what it's actually like to be in this age period and what are some of these concerns and some of the rewards. And then we can better support people when we know that. Well, Dr. Mehta, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been really interesting. Thank you. Oh, thank you so much. This was so much fun. Thank you for having me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, U.S., or wherever you get podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a
同样，能够获得一个多样化的样本，首先观察美国多种族、多族裔的情况。我的意思是，如果我有大量的资金，我会对全世界进行研究。但我认为这非常重要，因为它会告诉我们并提供更多细节，让我们了解这个年龄段的真实生活，以及其中的一些担忧和收获。当我们了解这些后，我们就能更好地支持人们。梅塔博士，感谢您今天参加我的节目。这真的非常有趣。谢谢。哦，非常感谢。这太有趣了。谢谢你邀请我。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、U.S. 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果你喜欢你所听到的内容，请订阅并给我们留下一个
review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
评论。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼制作。感谢收听。我是美国心理学会的基姆·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。